et nous recevons christophe prat
secrétaire général fo cheminots bonjour
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation une grande mobilisation est
donc attendu demain elle sera décisive
oui ce sera certainement décisive en
tout cas pour ce qui est de la
visibilité de la contestation qui sévit
maintenant depuis presque deux mois et
nous sommes d'ores et déjà assuré que ce
sera une grande réussite puisque puisque
beaucoup de gens seront mobilisés demain
important face à l'essoufflement du
mouvement de grève à la sncf et à la
ratp
est-ce que la protestation plus encore
posée comment est ce que vous voyez le
futur du mouvement de grèves et des
mobilisations
c'est c'est difficile de se projeter sur
un sur un futur
les nouvelles formes enfin la
contestation aujourd'hui prend prend des
nouvelles formes c'est vrai que plutôt
que par se parler d'essoufflement je
dirais qu'il ya certains secteurs qui
reprennent leur souffle et c'est bien
compréhensible après après plus de
cinquante jours de grève
pour autant nous avons vu la semaine
dernière et en ce début de semaine
d'autres secteurs aujourd'hui qui sont
mis en lumière leurs actions
leur mobilisation ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la détermination des
grévistes est notamment dans les
transports et les impacts
il faut s'attendre à de nouvelles formes
de contestation davantage d'actions coup
de poing comme on l'a vu c'est bien les
jours oui d'actions coup de poing de
forme inédite de contestation
aujourd'hui c'est malheureux mais on se
rend compte que les grévistes ne sont
pas entendus ils sont pas écoutés
écoutez on essaye juste de faire revenir
à la raison ce gouvernement et il faut
qu'il écoute aujourd'hui la contestation
la contestation elle n'est pas entendue
dès le départ ils ont joué plusieurs
cartes
ils ont joué la carte du mépris de
l'ignorance ça n'a pas fonctionné ils
ont joué la carte de la provocation ça
n'a pas fonctionné
aujourd'hui ils ont essayé aussi
l'explication ils ont tenté en tout cas
d'expliquer leurs projets il n'est pas
compris les rejetée majoritairement par
les français et pourtant il sera
présenté demain en conseil des ministres
les textes ensuite être transmis à
l'assemblée nationale alors vu d'un
premier débat d'un premier vote début
mars
au final finalement c'est le
gouvernement qui continue lui d'avancer
sur le projet oui c'est un entêtement
aujourd'hui plus de deux tiers des
français s'est encore confirmée dans
certains sondages parus hier deux tiers
des français demandent que le
gouvernement retire son projet et
soutiennent majoritairement
les grévistes qui demandent le retrait
pur et simple de ce projet donc nous ce
qu'on dit aujourd'hui c'est il faut
revenir à la raison
faut aujourd'hui apporté du calme dans
le pays de la sérénité et la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement c'est
aussi savoir dire on s'est trompé on
s'est entêté et puis finalement on se
rend bien compte que les gens n'adhèrent
pas et donc on retire alors la
mobilisation continue malgré tout c'est
ce que vous nous dites on a vu ce
sondage ans 61% des français interrogées
qui se déclarent pour le retrait de
cette réforme sur sur les retraites
est-ce que c'est suffisant selon vous
pour vous aider à vous faire entendre du
gouvernement
oui bah écoutez toute façon à partir
d'un moment où un projet plus que
majoritairement contestée
nous on pense que c'est largement
suffisant vous savez revenir en arrière
des fois c'est aussi une preuve de
de bon sens et quand on gouverne quand
on prétend gouverner un pays on gouverne
pas comme comme on peut diriger une
entreprise ou uniquement avec des des
paramètres financiers ou des paramètres
hypothétique
aujourd'hui le gouvernement il s'appuie
pour essayer de passer en force son
projet il s'appuie sur un rapport qui
émet des hypothèses
il pose des des dom dont il pose
carrément il dit il faudra pas dépenser
plus de 14 % des richesses
aujourd'hui c'est lui c'est lui
aujourd'hui qui bloque et qui ne veut
pas entendre aujourd'hui que les
français ne veulent pas de ce projet de
réforme est un mot peut-être aussi un du
retrait provisoire de la cheville au
c'était il ya quelques semaines
ça vous le mettez de côté aussi ce que
vous réclamez c'est toujours que ce soit
à retirer l'ensemble du projet de
réforme des retraites
est ce que vous êtes confiant est ce que
c'est quelque chose encore qui est
possible selon vous de la part du
gouvernement
tout est possible aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a les cartes en main
pour mettre fin à la contestation qui
est l'exigence du retrait total de cette
réforme
alors il peut aussi essayer encore une
fois il a essayé de passer l'âge du
grand-père dans plusieurs professions
l'arrêt il a essayé de passer l'âge
pivot en disant qu'hypothétique mans
vous l'avez dit provisoirement retiré
énoncé il est toujours inscrit
aujourd'hui dans le texte de loi il est
bien inscrit hd qui libre il est même
écrit des dizaines et des dizaines de
fois dans le texte non il sera pas
retirée et puis de toute façon c'est un
c'est un détail finalement dans les
paramètres de cette réforme puisque ce
qui est écrit c'est que les gens vont
devoir de toutes façons de travailler
plus longtemps pour avoir l'espérance
d'avoir une retraite qui est à peu près
équivalente à ce qu'on pourrait avoir
aujourd'hui
donc quand on vous dit vous devrez
cotisé de toute façon au moins quarante
trois années pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein
l'âge pivot de toute façon suivra et
s'allongera un bon peut-être de cette
bataille je sais pas bien quel quel mot
choisir mais ce qui se joue en ce moment
aussi entre la cgt et la cfdt la cgt qui
a revendiqué plusieurs actions menées
contre la cfdt vous vous êtes
représentant force ouvrière mais comment
est ce que vous voyez ces actions de la
cgt notamment il ya une guerre syndicale
qui se joue aussi je crois pas que ce
soit une guerre syndicale
je crois que encore une fois finalement
c'est ce gouvernement qui à être qu'à
essayer encore de monter les gens les
uns contre les autres au début c'étaient
les professions il a voulu faire croire
que c'était pour mettre fin aux régimes
spéciaux pour opposer les gens avec les
eaux certains avaient plus certains
avaient moins ce n'est pas égal on
parlait d' inégalités etc
en réalité c'est pas ça c'est pas une
guerre entre la cgt et laurent berger
chacun à sa posture nous pour force
ouvrière on est on est on n'est plus du
on est plus proche des d'ailleurs on est
on est sur les mêmes revendications que
la cgt par contre il faut pas dire que
c'est la cgt qui organise des blocages
des qui organise des exactions comme
j'ai pu entendre quoi que ce soit
annoncé les grévistes qui veulent se
faire entendre et aujourd'hui toutes
formes d'actions à l'europe peut être
contestable
elles sont surtout légitime merci
beaucoup pour votre réaction christophe
prat je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire fédéral fo cheminots
merci